what's happening now in the United
States is very similar what happened to
Detroit at the Industrial Revolution
right which is that you're seeing this
change from industrial to digital and
Miami is the only city in America that
got the memo and has basically uh built
its entire economy to capitalize on what
I call a tsunami of opportunity and
cities like New York and and San
Francisco and Silicon Valley thought
they were too big to fail and I'll tell
you Dave they're not
um the world is more disruptive than
other companies that are massive get
disrupted out of existence like that and
um we are building for the future and
it's exciting to see
all right I'm Dave Rubin we are at the
local Studio here in Miami and I am with
the mayor of Miami Francis Suarez who
loves Miami fair to say you love Miami
nobody loves my everyone loves Miami but
like you love me there's no separation
between me and Miami right like first of
all just coming here and seeing this
incredible studio in the heart of
Wynwood in Miami which is one of the
most dynamic fun exciting neighborhoods
it's totally on brand for you right and
uh you know it's just exciting to see
you here and uh we so we totally Embrace
what you're doing you know in terms of
the content the conversations that
you're provoking and it's very much in
line with who we are as a city so it's
just it's just fun and exciting to be
here so I asked my guys right before we
started I sat down with you in Miami
Beach in June of 2021 that's right so
it's about a year a little less than a
year and a half ago I was not a
Floridian I was not really thinking
about Florida there was a little there
was a little bit of it
agree there was a little something but a
lot has changed for for me and this
company and and you're basically in
charge of the city that everyone is
coming to right now how do you feel
about that because I know it's good but
it also comes with some some stuff
that's tough right so look first of all
as the first mayor of Miami that was
born in Miami right in the 125 year
history of Miami this is a dream come
true I feel like every day I'm living a
dream insofar as I was born here I grew
up here went to college here uh lost
your dad was mayor my dad was a mayor
from when I was eight years old to when
I was 16 so I saw this sort of evolution
of the city very up close uh and and to
be in a situation where we have set up a
city to be successful when a lot of
urban cities in America are not
successful or failing and we did it
because we followed three Simple Rules
we keep taxes low we keep people safe
and we lean into Innovation so you know
we have created a city that's number one
in Tech job growth right number one in
wage growth we have a city that because
we've kept taxes low has grown 12
percent which is the second most in
recorded history and with all that
additional Revenue even though you lower
taxes you actually have more Revenue
right you know spoiler for New York and
California right uh we have actually
done the opposite of what other cities
have done which have defunded their
police with increased funding for police
more officers than ever another shocking
correlation
our crime is about to be God willing you
know and knock on Woodward right there
we're not in December yet uh but we are
on the precipice of having the lowest
per capita homicide rate in history yeah
so it's exciting time to be here in
Miami so much has changed in the last
year and a half and it's everywhere in
Miami not just right here because
although I don't want to say the
specific part of town that I live in you
know and in the in the area that I
learned there hasn't been a home
breaking in 14 years I mean the the
flourishing is every day I wake up and
there's a new Los Angelino coming to my
town now I'm starting to worry but and
I've been in an elected office for 13
years so maybe there's a correlation
between the 14 and the 13. but look I I
think uh you're right uh people Miami
was the best kept secret number one
number two Miami has always punched
above its weight right when you think
about what is Miami I mean you could
arguably have someone who lives in Palm
Beach who is in Paris and they ask them
where are you from they say Miami right
just sort of this is this big thing
right this I always say Miami's an idea
it's more than a city and it's an idea
born out of a trauma what's a trauma
trauma is many people in mind were
kicked out of their country of birth
were exiled because a leader in their
country said give me all your businesses
give me all your property don't worry
we'll make everything equal and you know
what they did they made everything equal
equally miserable for everybody right
and so we are traumatized by that and I
think that's why miamians are so
fundamentally pro-america we're so
fundamentally Pro uh you know sort of
fair market and free market and we
believe in freedom and liberty right
those are principles that for us we we
fought for right we we've we've been my
grandfather was in jail in Cuba my his
brother died in a Cuban jail you know
it's very very real for us
so on the tax side you you wrote a piece
in Wall Street Journal about a month or
a month and a half ago talking about
free markets and capitalism and why this
place is start is thriving so how does
it make any sense I thought you the
government just needs more of our money
to make things work but you're keeping
taxes low and so and we don't have you
know roads exploding and all sorts of
stuff yeah yeah it's it's so
counterintuitive how is it possible so
let's let's let me give you a real
example right if you are living in New
York City right now cost of living
differential between New York and Miami
is two to one so in New York the median
home price is a million dollars in Miami
median home price is 540 two to one
right in addition to that in New York
you're paying fifth if you're in the
highest tax bracket a lot of New Yorkers
are because again your cost of living
well they're all coming down here now
well but check it out let's do the math
right you're paying 54 cents out of
every dollar in taxes that means that
for every dollar you earn you take home
46 cents in Miami you get 63 cents right
it is a huge Delta right and so that
when you at scale obviously is Inc
incredibly uh motivating to people you
know I've seen statistics that seventy
percent of the taxes in New York are
paid by 8 000 people and if that becomes
seventy five hundred and seven thousand
sixty five hundred you get what's called
a vicious cycle right you get massive
holes in your budget when those people
leave and there's only one way to get
more revenue for them which is to
increase taxes which creates more
migration more holes and I call it the
death spiral so what's happening now in
the United States is very similar what
happened to Detroit at the Industrial
Revolution right which is that you're
seeing this change from industrial to
digital and Miami is the only city in
America that got the memo and has
basically uh built its entire economy to
capitalize on what I call a tsunami of
opportunity and cities like New York and
and San Francisco and Silicon Valley
thought they were too big to fail and
I'll tell you Dave they're not
um the world is more disruptive than
other companies that are massive get
disrupted out of existence like that and
um we are building for the future and
it's exciting to see do you get any
pushback from other Mayors who are going
hey Francis you know if you keep taxes
low it's going to make us look like a
bunch of idiots because we got the grift
going here and it's kind of working
until until it doesn't work you know
I'll tell you this I'm President of the
U.S conference mayor so president all
the Mayors in the country
um and and what I get more of and I got
to be careful how I say this because I
get more of the cameras not on listen we
really think what you're doing is great
yeah yeah but we we don't have the
ability to do it it's that's more the
sentiment that I get right which is why
would it may or not have the abilities
because of the local I think there's a
variety of reasons I think they get a
lot of pressure from the Press right
which has this their own agenda right
which is a grow government government is
a solver of every problem agenda I think
they've got to deal with uh institutions
like for example when I first got
elected in 2009 I was the only candidate
elected without Union support because I
wouldn't lie to the unions and tell them
look we're gonna raise your pay when
we're in a recession right you know and
when when we have to cut 20 of our
budget in one year which is another
thing that's another lie right which is
that government can't balance his budget
listen I have to 20 percent for my
budget in one year 150 million dollars
at a 600 million dollar budget if I can
cut 20 in one year we can balance our
budget at the federal level and the city
didn't fall apart and they said no on
the contrary it started thriving right
so we balanced our budget we were at 13
million in reserves at the time 2009 in
November now we're at 150 million
reserves the most reserves we've ever
had we have the highest Bond rating
under my uh Administration ever in the
in the history of the city which is
double A plus one away from the highest
which is Triple A so we're incredibly
fiscally sound uh and it's all by just
you're sort of following the same
formula that you would if you're a
homeowner right like your own personal
save a little bit of money pay off your
credit cards you know pay your debt uh
don't overspend right and then spend
strategically on the things that are
going to make you more successful invest
in yourself invest in you know policing
keeping people safe that kind of thing
what kind of pushback do you get from
the Democrats here when you're doing
some of these things so you're lowering
taxes you're putting police on the
street I mean one thing for sure that I
notice here is that when I go to New
York and I see cops all over the place
to me it's a sign that something is not
right right when I go here and I see
cops whether it's in South Beach or down
where I am it's like oh they're they're
patrolling and just making sure
everything's okay it's a huge difference
in mentality and I think the other
difference of massage would support them
right I think I think in other cities
they don't feel supported yeah what you
got to understand is right now in in
America being a police officer is the
hardest job in America it's harder than
being a roofer okay you've got there
isn't a job in America where you get
paid less money with more scrutiny and
more risk right and more at stake and
being asked to do more things because
now they're being asked to be social
workers I mean it's really really hard
to be a police officer in America and I
think fundamentally number one they need
to be protected they need to be sort of
supported right number two uh they need
to be well paid right like anybody in
life right like you you've got to
support them financially because they've
got got to take care of their kids they
want their kids to go to school just
like you do and so we've been we've been
blessed and then you have to have a lot
of police officers because it creates a
deterrent effect we've given them a ton
of Technology uh to be to help them
leverage their you know the sort of a
force multiplier and all of that has
been incredibly successful in
maintaining our homicide rate where it
is what are some of the stresses of
having all these people move here I mean
house prices for sure you mentioned
they're lower than New York but it's
it's tough to get a place here and one
of the things I'm always worried about
and I I see emails from this is that
people that are the OG Floridians who
have done it right and lived here for a
long time they're suddenly feeling oh we
could get priced out because all of
these rich people from LA and New York
located
we are a victim of our success yeah
right
um what happens is first of all you have
historic inflation so here's a problem
with governments saying we're going to
solve the the inflation crisis by giving
everybody money right so you are you're
in a level where we're at historic
inflation if you look at Urban America
right now not just Miami Urban America
Rents are up 25 or more in every urban
city big city in America Miami is more
like 35 45 why because you layer on top
a lot of hyper demand we're all people
are just fleeing getting the heck out of
places where they think they're not
wanted or where they think they're
getting taxed to death uh or where they
think the economy is moving away from so
I know the feeling you have all these
things happening right and so that is
definitely putting pressure on Miami no
doubt about it I I would be uh lying if
I didn't say that were the case but what
makes us different and why will we
thrive in the in the face of that stress
couple of things one is New York is
completely built out
um I think they built the last building
in Park Avenue in the last 50 years just
got built right uh San Francisco's
artificially constrained right with
their zoning code Miami has the ability
to grow 10x we're in a neighborhood
right now Winwood which has explosive
growth you see it when you walk out you
feel it here you can see it's ready we
have the ability to grow the Delta
between what's built and what can be
built is a ten to one multiple so we can
supply ourselves at a level where
um you know where we can keep prices
relatively low we have just to give you
some numbers about 185 000 dwelling
units in the city proper in the pipeline
right now to be built in the next 24 to
36 months we have 47 000 dwelling units
so that's a 25 increase in our entire
building stock so that's number one
number two we do affordable housing in a
way that is sort of private sector
oriented we do the carrot approach not
the stick we don't tell developers this
is what you have to do we tell
developers look we want to be a part of
your Capital stack we will do you know
we'll give you a dollar for every 15
that you invest in the product or every
twenty dollars your investment project
and the only caveat for our dollar is
you got to maintain rents at a certain
level for a certain period of time
that's it it's a carrot you want the
carrot this is what you got to do to get
it if you don't want it it's okay so
they can build either way absolutely 100
interesting they can do Market or if
they want to do something uh different
they can do affordable housing and we
have built and we will build probably
between four and a half and six billion
dollars of affordable housing over the
next five to ten years here in Miami in
addition to the supply can you also talk
about the the homeless situation because
there basically isn't a homeless
situation at least compared to other
major cities so Florida it's pretty nice
seems like people would want to come
down here right so don't give away ideas
yeah no no I mean
yeah
20 of my audience is homeless so look
we're blessed we have systematically
invested and we did it in a way that was
really smart right so we have something
called the homeless trust and it is a
tax right we don't like to pay taxes but
this is a tourist tax so this is for
people who are coming to Miami staying
in hotels they pay one percent uh on
their bill right and it funds a homeless
trust so basically there are visitors
not not our residents are paying this
tax our visitors are basically paying a
tax that goes to help what I call the
least the last and the lost the most uh
marginalized in our community and so you
know what have we done we built a
decentralized set of centers that give
them alcohol uh treatment drug treatment
mental health treatment and vocational
training right in addition to that we're
spending over the next two years about
seven million dollars in a plan that I
call functional zero so we have 640
homeless right now six four zero
according to our last census that's it
that's it that's it wow but I want to be
at zero because I don't think any city
in America is really chopped big city
has really challenged himself to get to
zero and I think that if we create a
model then it can be certainly um
exported right to the rest of the
country that are dealing with tens of
thousands of homeless in their cities
yeah and again this is one of those
things where I just see these other
Mayors it's like why don't you just look
at Miami and fix things I went to Denver
yeah I did not you know Denver is not
San Francisco Denver is not and I love
the mayor of Denver yeah but I was like
but what's going on here look I I think
I had a mayor and I won't say who it was
from a big city one of the one of the
top 20 cities in America tell me
recently we just waited too long you
know we didn't do what you guys did we
used to have 9 000 homeless we bought it
from 9 000 to a thousand right uh and a
thousand is in the county which is 2.8
million people uh only about 600 of that
thousand is in the actual City proper
which is my jurisdiction so um so we did
it through this decentralized network a
lot of these cities just didn't do it
and then of course we're seeing a lot of
mismanagement a lot of I mean I've heard
some crazy statistics in California
where people are paying like four or
five hundred thousand dollars homeless
or something like that yeah and it's
just money that's there's no controls
it's Rife with you know a variety of
problems and So that obviously is not
going to work uh let's talk a little bit
about the the hurricane situation
because obviously it ended up hearkening
and ended up hitting Southwest Florida
where obviously in southeast Florida but
at first it was going to hit here
obviously hurricanes do hit Miami yeah
um you've been you've been tweeting
about it and doing doing all sorts of
stuff
um what do we need to know for the for
the Miami and the future of Miami and
who's going to come down here or to
Florida in general when it comes to
these storms so to be honest and I'm you
know again as President of the U.S
Conference of marriage I was uh I led a
delegation uh to to the Gulf Coast to
see all the cities that were impacted in
the Gulf Coast and it was devastating
and I uh there's two things that I think
everybody needs to know uh thing number
one is for every dollar that we as a
community as a country spend on the
front end in resiliency investment we
saved seven to eight dollars on the back
end so I was just uh at a podcast today
an interview where they were saying that
Senator Rubio's um advocating for 33
billion dollars of spending for
Hurricane Relief
so my point is if we would have spent 5
billion on the front end we could have
potentially saved 25 to 30 billion on
the back end you're talking about
building new structures I'm talking
about things like buildings that I'm
talking about things like like like
Urban reservoirs pumps pumps uh
increased sea walls uh you know backflow
preventers these are all the things that
we're doing in Miami right now okay uh
in Miami we posted Hurricane Andrew
which was in 1992 which was a 200 mile
an hour wind event we basically made
Miami the most wind resiliency on the
planet like we're bunker right the
problem now is water and water volume
what we've seen in the last two years
are two events that frankly are super
frightening
um Ian and Dorian I don't know if you
remember Dorian from a couple years ago
Dorian was a category five that sat on
top of the Bahamas never touched a
continental US that I'm aware of maybe
maybe up North but certainly didn't
touch Florida and It produced 25-foot of
storm surge so Ian has produced 10 plus
foot of storms you're talking about 25
so Mother Nature has just shown us two
massively destructive events that no
city in the world is prepared for you
know period full stop yeah we've got to
start being creative we've got to start
you know one of the great things about
this country is it's Innovative Spirit
right it's it's it's it's ability to
solve problems complex problems right
you know we get thrown challenges uh we
we solve them we're the first country to
invent you know a nuclear bomb you know
during World War II right which
obviously um as you know heinous as it
was we used it in the end of the war
could have say who knows what would have
happened if we did we didn't have that
technology we have always been a country
that finds a way to to solve big
problems and this is a big problem and I
I think um you know we're gonna have to
really dedicate you know a ton of
resources to try to solve it because the
scale of these problems are much bigger
than what we've seen how does that work
related to the city level versus the
state level I mean you know how proud I
am to be a Floridian but watching
Governor DeSantis just go from every
Community every freaking day and you
could see the media the media was doing
what they do with you like when we had
when we had one day of water in Brickell
there was one picture yeah he's getting
out of a club and they because they want
to use it again exercise but can you
talk a little bit about how the the
cities have to operate with this stuff
versus the versus the state house so
I'll give you a sense of the differences
in our budgets we got about a billion
and a half taller budget the state has a
110 billion dollar budget so it's about
a hundred to one right approximately so
you know definitely the state we need
the state we also need the federal
government under President Trump he had
proposed a 1.5 trillion dollar uh
infrastructure bill would ultimately
ended up getting passed uh was a 1.2
trillion dollar uh infrastructure bill
that money I haven't it's it's like a
joke I haven't seen prevent any of that
money yet so have you have you called
anybody oh yeah we've called a bunch of
people hey when is this thing going to
flow right yeah so I think but I think
look infrastructure is a legitimate
expense for the federal government if
it's spent properly and if it doesn't
you know produce massive deficits which
unfortunately it has right but I think
at the end of the day you know we need
piece of that money so that we can spend
money on the front end to again avoid
having to spend more money on the back
end how confident are you that Florida
is going to stay in good shape like it
is obviously we've got elections coming
in a couple weeks you mentioned Senator
Rubio obviously Governor just had this I
mean it really feels like things are
functional here and working I mean to
watch those bridges get rebuilt the Pine
Island Bridge Causeway in two weeks I
mean it's it's incredible stuff but how
confident are you that it's going to
keep kind of moving in this direction so
I'm gonna I'll give you the good news
and the you know the the worrisome news
right so the good news is that Trump won
Florida by a hundred thousand votes in
16 and 400 000 votes in 20. so the trend
is favorable in addition to that
Republicans for the first time I think
in history or maybe in like 40 years
outnumbered Democrats right so I think
it's about 250 000 votes yeah as of the
last uh last time I looked at it so
that's the good news right so all that
indicates strength for Republicans
Republicans should win at all level 2018
which was the last election like this
was very close the governor I think won
by 35 000 votes uh Senator Scott won by
like 14 000 votes and in that same
election a Democrat won statewide right
so um that just which goes to show just
the variability of Florida
um the worrisome news is that in Florida
there and people don't talk about this I
don't know why they don't talk about it
but they should there's 20 to 25 percent
of the entire electorate is MPA it's a
huge number right no party affiliation
oh okay right so they're not Republicans
Or democrats so when you're talking
about you know four million people that
are NPA if 50 of them vote that's two
million votes so you could win
Republicans by 250 000 votes but the
mpas got to drop dry uh they've got to
break your way yeah right and so that's
if somehow something bad happens I
guarantee you that would be why it would
happen yeah so you know we'll see I
think I think what do you do to get
those people I mean I guess you just
look are you making it work yeah you
keep making it work um I think a lot of
those people even even in even in a
county like Dade County which is a
predominantly Democrat County right uh
I'll give you an example or something
the former president did right he lost
Dade County in 16 by 30 votes 30 I'm
sorry right and he only lost it in 20 by
eight percent so when you talk about
that increase from 100 000 to 400 000 it
almost comes exactly back to Dade County
because it's the 22 Delta on a million
200 000 voters right so what did he do
um he was strong in Venezuela right he
was bold and he uh recognized Guido and
got a coalition of countries to
recognize Juan Guido to try to disrupt
the my little regime uh what did he do
on Cuba he rolled back all the Obama
giveaways right during Obama's
presidency who wanted he wanted a legacy
Victory kind of like Nixon's China
opening right with Cuba and and putting
an embassy there and we got nothing in
return right uh Trump undid that so 75
percent of new arrival Cubans voted for
Donald Trump yeah it's really
fascinating I mean that these people
know it and they get it of course
there's no other issues that are near
and dear to their heart so when someone
speaks to those issues people are loyal
about it so we're gonna in a little bit
we're gonna bring in asafo is the CEO of
locals but I just want to talk you
broadly on the tech side before we talk
about what we're doing so you brought in
all these Tech well you brought him in I
mean basically you sent out a tweet you
said how can I help next thing you know
all these tech people show up we've
talked about this a little bit once or
twice before but you know there's always
the fear from the original Floridians oh
they're going to bring all the bad ideas
sure what do you think well I'll say two
things one is uh it was a counter
narrative right what was happening in
American cities New York pushed on
Amazon after hq2 yep and people don't
realize it's not just that you're
pushing out 50 000 high-paying jobs
right it's the signaling effect what are
you telling your own residents that
you're taxing to death things aren't
going to get better we don't want you
here get out of here because we don't
value people who achieve the American
dream California F Elon Musk Elon says
message received I'm out of here same
thing you're not only losing the world's
richest person frankly you're losing
something much worse than that you're
losing their jobs from those companies
or again signaling effect we don't want
you here if you're successful which to
me is an anti-American sentiment when
somebody says Hey what if we move
Silicon Valley to Miami and I respond
how can I help what am I saying I love
this country I'm saying I want you to be
successful I'm saying I want my
residents to be successful and I think
what happens is the media feeds our
residents one thing and one thing only
government is here to help you on the
expense side we're here to give you
housing we're here to give you you know
transportation and and I unlock
something that I thought was
counterintuitive and by the way didn't
you know the Press sometimes give me a
hard time about it which is I want to
help you fish not just give you a fish I
want to teach you how to fish I want you
to be empowered I want I want all my
residents to get the best paying jobs to
be able to provide for their family so
that they don't need an affordable house
affordable housing uh apartment that
they can buy whatever apartment they
want that their kids could go to good
schools you know I want my people to be
successful and I think I I don't know
why that's controversial uh at times you
know I I get I get criticized because
it's like all about you but but you
don't care about no I do I care I've
spent 12 years of my life building
affordable housing and and mass transit
uh free you know trolley systems in our
city now I want people to be successful
and I spend a lot of my time and energy
on that you know in terms of some people
who um who find that find it harder for
them
um you know it my heart goes out to them
because obviously you want everybody to
be successful and you you want people to
embrace the competitive uh scenario that
we're in
um but it reminds me a little bit of I
don't know if you ever saw my primary
colors yeah I saw it 20 20 years anyway
yeah yeah there's a scene where the
Clinton character was John Travolta
actually says you know I'm gonna do
something very outrageous I'm gonna tell
you the truth I don't know how many
times
but anyways uh and what he says is he's
telling a union organization that he he
that the jobs that left that factory are
never coming back but that what he said
was that he's going to teach them to
exercise a different set of muscles the
one between their ears right and I think
as our economy becomes more digital
unfortunately the economy that we're
going to be living in is going to be
more experiential content-based
and it's going to be more technological
so we're going to have to get better and
in getting better we're gonna we're
gonna Thrive okay willing how at odds do
you feel like you are with the current
Administration
I think we're at odds on on a lot of
issues look we're in odds on government
spending right they've they've created
this inflation now in California they're
giving thousand dollars in
anti-inflation which is going to create
more inflation so they've experience
they always raise the taxes and then
they give you your money back and you're
supposed to thank them for it exactly
something and by the way it just creates
inflation right right right so you've
got more inflation so you've got a you
know dysfunctional foreign policy you
know disastrous retreat in Afghanistan
conventional war in Ukraine which
obviously this Administration wasn't
able to avoid
um you know you've got
um uh this oil situation in in in in the
entire world right where you have oil
prices that are dependent on on foreign
uh you know producers uh the dependency
of Europe on Russia you've got South
America going socialist more and more in
the US having no coherent policy on that
um you know we have systematically
ignored Cuba's role as the head of the
snake in exporting its only commodity
which is communism and doing it very
effectively because they were trained by
the Russians in the 1970s and and and
you know their supply chain issues I
mean they have really not confronted
successfully in my opinion any of the
macro issues that are generational uh in
nature that are going to set up this
country for Success where are you at on
the on the immigration stuff generally
obviously we had this big thing with the
Martha's Vineyards sure that whole thing
um I don't even really know actually how
the city falls on when people just show
up here and all that stuff yeah look I
mean we're a city of immigrants right
um mostly legal immigrants frankly um
because you know Cubans had a favorable
immigration policy called you know web
for dry food and what preceded it so you
were able to get a Asylum essentially
automatically I just don't think we're
having a very coherent conversation
about it you know on both sides right I
think uh when you look at a city like
Miami we have 1.4 unemployment that's
awesome until you want to start until
you want to start a small business and
then you can't find employees yeah right
so the beauty of us of America versus
China for example is we both have
declining birth rates and the difference
is nobody wants to go to China everybody
wants to come here so I think that's an
opportunity if we have a conversation
that benefits the U.S right as opposed
to just a border conversation right and
I think that's where I hope the future
of this conversation goes because this
is an unresolved issue that is not it
reminds me of world war one trench
warfare everybody's sort of in their
side just gonna poke up they get back in
and then you know in a year they maybe
move four inches right so there's just
no coherent discussion on it so so what
do we do in Miami like what's the policy
if somehow illegals get here yeah I'm
not even sure where the Martha's
Vineyard one started or how they ended
up yeah or roughly here yeah but what is
the city's policy on well we don't we
don't we're not ice right yeah so so we
don't have a formal role yeah
um so that's an ice issue right the
federal government immigrations custom
Enforcement issue as to whether or not
um how they detain people and and what
they do with them once they're detained
so we don't have a role in that we don't
we don't get in their way either you
know we sort of let them do their job
and support them uh if and when
necessary but um you know again part of
what makes us special is our diversity
right and our inclusion in terms of a
variety of different people that come
from a variety of different backgrounds
and that's what makes us who we are so I
also think for the Republican party I
think this is important Hispanics are
trending Republican right and I think it
why why is that happening in part
because Democrats don't know how to
speak to them right they either call
them latinx
come on which which does not resonate
when you go macro right when you and
then when you go nuanced you call them a
San Antonio taco right so so they don't
get the macro branding they don't get
the nuanced Brandy and I think this is
an awesome opportunity for Republicans
to say hey we respect you
um we know you want to be Americans we
know you're law-abiding we know that you
believe in family
um and and you want to you know you
believe in the family unit as a means of
trying to get people to be successful in
education these are all of the things
that Republicans oh always talk about
right so you know there's a great
opportunity there to lean into that and
not be worried that if you know
something happens on the immigration
front it's going to be damaging to
Republicans it actually might be very
beneficial you mean you're telling me
that Latinos just like everyone else
care about more than one issue they do
isn't that why and they care about our
country very bizarre let me ask you one
that actually look at how many southern
Texas border in Congressional races no
it's incredible Republican women that
are going to hopefully sweep three
Congressional race including one that I
think they hadn't held for 150 years
Myra Flores and she's the one that then
the New York Times ran the article uh
what was it the the Latino face of the
new right or something or the alt-right
something insane let me ask you one
about that I saw some of my guys giving
you some crap for which is some of the
gun buyback stuff and this thing so I
saw my more conservative side it's
coming for guns he's a Democrat
something like that so I allow you to
clean it up however well first of all I
think people that like you generally
that live in this city anything I'll
tell you this
um
let's see how I put this sort of a
little bit delicately right yeah there's
a lot of jocking going on right now and
there's a lot of surrogates that are
doing a lot of things to try to build
people up and tear people down kill them
in the crib type of thing there's a lot
of that happening with me as my profile
gets bigger as I get um talked about in
more prominent circles it's more like
hey let's try to Brand him as a certain
thing right and there's a lot of that
happening with me um but you know gun
buyback is something that the city's
been doing forever right and it's not
about
um you know being pro-gon or Antigone
I'm I'm firmly Pro Second Amendment I'm
a gun owner and an incredibly Pro police
I think really more it's more for you
know what happens oftentimes is like a
widow right whose husband passes and and
the husband was an avid gun collector
and they have 20 30 guns at home and
they're afraid that if somebody breaks
in they're gonna steal the guns and kill
them or hurt somebody else so they just
don't feel safe with the guns at home
and they prefer to sell it these you
know these oftentimes are elderly people
who are living on fixed income right and
they get you know we have like uh what
do you call it a coupon so we give them
or or you know um I forget what they're
called uh sort of a gift cards that we
give them right and so we'll give them
gift cards to Publix or gift cards to
Target or whatever and they'd rather
have you know fifteen hundred dollars in
gift cards to Target than 20 guns that
they don't know what they're doing with
right in their own home so that's that's
the that's the prototypical scenario so
it's not like we want to take guns off
the street in that sense or we want
people not to it's completely voluntary
right so people want to do it they do it
if they don't want to do it they don't
have to do it do we even have a gun
problem I mean is there are there
shootings here really like so so that
that's the other thing is that you know
in this in this conversation about gun
violence you know people it's such a
myopic conversation right we don't talk
about the fact that uh in Miami for
example we have we were ranked the
happiest city in America the healthiest
city in America with 1.4 unemployment
and increasing funding for police
departments so it turns out if you have
more police officers Happy People
healthy people and people that are
working guess what they're not killing
other people right so that's the formula
for Six Happiness may come from not
being killed by the way that has nothing
to do with whether they own a gun or
don't own a gun that has to do with
their frame of mind it has to do with
where they what they are in life and I
often said look you know if somebody
wants to hurt somebody there are
unfortunately a multitude of ways that
that can happen and so we've got to look
at the root cause of why people feel
compelled to do X and where we're
missing and I think that that gets lost
in the discussion a lot do you think the
happy part is I mean and literally it's
not you're not making it up I mean it
was voted to happen multiple years you
can see you can see it there I mean
people and it's not just the weather
there I think it obviously is connected
to the spirit of freedom and all those
things and toxic when you have to pay so
much in taxes you're happier right like
you you know at the end of the day we
want to look I have this concept called
return on time right we think about
return investment right Roi right even
think about and and people don't realize
that their most precious commodity is
their time right it's the only thing
that we all have in common that is
finite right we can't make more of it I
mean we can be healthy and hopefully you
know we have good genetics you know
hopefully we live longer but we're all
basically you know uh con conforming to
a life that is a certain amount of time
and I think we uh I've got to build our
city around that concept and if you see
the world it's it's going to that
concept it's experiential right
restaurants uh virtual reality metaverse
it's content podcasts
um YouTube Etc and then it's it's Sports
it's you know uh experiential and parks
and things like that and that's how you
build a city that I think uh really
respects people's most precious
commodity on that note we're going to
take a 10 second break we're going to
bring in a soft because a year and a
half ago I said yeah I'm thinking about
it and you said basically how can I help
and and it's happening I love it all
right if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell